[Music]
[Music]
just passing through a sleepy little
town called adventure back over
oh that's cold that's cold oh
i got blue slushy in my scabies
little guys
[Music]
oh no no no no no no oh
[Music]
oh my that's not good that's not good at
all good morning there friend looks like
you're in a particularly precarious
predicament
call the police call the fire department
call everybody
you're an adventure bay here we call the
paw patrol you're gonna call the who
paw patrol paw patrol will be there on
the double whenever there's a problem
round adventure bay
rather than his team of pups will come
and save the day marshall rubble chase
rocky zuma skye yeah on the way paw
patrol paw patrol whenever you're in
trouble
paw patrol paw patrol will be there on
the double no job's too big no puck's
too small paw patrol we're on a roll
so
[Music]
here we go let's work together up there
rocky i need you to shut down the bridge
and control traffic
[Music]
zuma i need you to keep that waterway
clear nobody under the bridge
you've got it right
waterway secure
[Music]
chase it's all up to you use the winch
in your pup pack to get the driver and
bring him to safety chase is on the case
[Music]
sir don't be alarmed i'm coming down oh
thank you thank you thank you the rescue
team is here
a dog
actually sir i'm a puppy
a baby dog that's even worse you're in
shock so i'm not gonna take that
personally now let's get you out of here
no way i'm waiting right here for a real
rescue
i changed my mind i'll go with you
these cables aren't going to hold much
longer let's go chase get them out of
there we're coming out
don't panic i need you to stay calm
no deal i'm freaking out then you're
really not gonna like this
[Music]
you can open your eyes now
oh we made it
great work paw patrol
[Applause]
everybody get back the truck's leaking
gas
[Music]
oh come on that's not gas that's the
stuff i've been holding from coast to
coast that is pure canadian maple syrup
okay time to clean up this mess deploy
waffles pancakes and french toast
[Laughter]
it's okay little guy you're safe
you can come out now
let's get you back to your family
[Music]
great work pups another perfect rescue
[Music]
paw patrol is on a roll
[Music]
ride don't you know oh
we got the sun now we're shining
wherever
[Music]
i turn around
[Music]
[Music]
now
oh
[Music]
bye